♪ I know you ♪
♪ Don't worry, baby ♪
Happy Thanksgiving week, y'all.
Countdown to Turkey Day.
Okay, I'm here waiting
on my aunties.
How you gon' miss three flights
in one day?
My family. But...
a little pregame ain't never
hurt nobody.
(CACKLES) Sorry,
I gotta take this. Urgent.
Hello? (CACKLES)
-Kelli's hosting
all her aunties?
-Yep.
-Even the one who--
How many of these
do you usually use?
About 12.
For a seven layer dip,
do you think you need that many?
'Cause I avoca-don't.
(LAUGHS)
I probably need more.
My dad inhales this shit.
Oh, so you and your dad
are good?
Hell naw, it's just dip.
And I've accepted the fact
that our relationship
won't be same,
and I'm fine with that.
Well, shit. Be thankful
your parents
don't have new families.
Me and Ahmal gotta celebrate
with Stanley this year.
Your mama still with him?
Yolanda love her a project.
And she's obsessed with getting
to know his kids.
Like why can't I just overeat
and binge drink
with my own blood?
Wait. Does that mean you're not
coming over for pie this year?
Oh, bitch, best believe
I'm coming over. Okay?
I'mma eat that pie
all the way out.
I'mma fuck that pie. Up.
I'mma fuck that pie up.
You know, I've been going back
and forth with this,
but should I invite Andrew?
I mean, we are exclusive now.
Hmm, I don't know, girl.
I mean, y'all only been talkin,
what, two, three months?
You gon' pull an old Molly
and scare his ass away.
(SIGHS)